[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT ANTHONY: Thank you, Jane.
Good afternoon, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
SCOTT ANTHONY: There
was a pregnant pause
before I said anything there,
so let's try that again.
I am going to try and make
this interactive as we
go through the materials here.
I will be pulling you
into the conversation,
and I will have time
at the end for Q&A.
So we do need people to
provide cues when I ask for it.
So let's try that again.
Good afternoon, everyone.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
SCOTT ANTHONY: A very
trainable, malleable audience.
I like that a lot.
Well, I am thrilled to be here.
I've been in the innovation
field by my count
for about 18 years now.
And I've spoken at
a few Google events,
but I've never actually been
inside a Google campus, which
I find rather astonishing.
So today is my first day.
Thank you for having me.
I am thrilled to
share with you some
of our thoughts about leadership
lessons from the trenches
of disruption.
The way I decided to
organize today's remarks
is in five acts.
Act one is the origin story.
This starts with
contemplating a question
that I ask people to
think about all the time.
If a young person asked
you, what should I
do if I want to change the
world, how do you respond?
I asked you, who came to this
event, to answer this question.
And I've asked now about
2,000 people around the world
this question over
the last few years.
What kind of responses
do people give?
Well, the dominant response
today is to start a company.
Almost 40% of the people
that I've asked this
question to give
that as their answer.
And 50% of you said
the same thing.
That is the perception
that people have.
You do what Steve
Jobs and Steve Wozniak
and Larry and Sergey
and others did.
You go and create a new company.
Become a teacher is
another popular answer.
Almost 30% of people say that.
Go and join a
not-for-profit comes
in third in the poll
with 17% of people
saying this is the path to
go and change the world.
We're left with two at
the bottom of the barrel.
Either join a great big company
or enter public service.
I am sad to report that
public service is the lowest
ranked response in my survey.
It used to be a
little bit higher,
but it's declined pretty sharply
over the past couple years.
I can't think of
any global events
that lead to that happening.
But now only 8%
of people say this
is what you do if you
want to change the world.
But I want to look at this
number for just a second.
Only 9% of people say do
what you have all done.
Google today, of course,
is not a startup company.
It is a great big global giant.
People say this is not the path
that you should follow if you
want to change the world.
I thought this.
The reason I moved out
to Singapore in 2010
wasn't to take the
consulting business
that I'd helped build
in the United States
and bring it to Southeast Asia.
No, I was going to leave
that part of our business
behind, where we advise great
big companies on how they can
navigate disruptive change and
joined a sister company that we
had set up called Innosight
Ventures, whose intent was
to invest in and
incubate startup
companies, because, after all,
I wanted to change the world.
And that's what you do, right?
You enter the
entrepreneurial ecosystem.
Well, in October 2010
I had a paired set
of experiences that
showed me I had
framed the problem incorrectly.
That, in fact, the
best thing to do
if you want to
change the world is
to do exactly what you have done
and join a great big company.
I call this the
Parable of Plunify
and the Might of
the Multinational.
Let me start with Plunify.
Plunify was a startup
company that pitched us
for funding in October 2010.
The details of
Plunify don't matter.
The important part
of the story is
it was the first
time we were pitched
for funding not with a business
plan, but with a business.
What's the difference, you ask?
Well, a business plan
is facts and figures
and slides and spreadsheets.
A business is customers.
A business is a website.
A business is actual revenues.
The two kids
pitching for funding
had done all this,
spending basically $0.
This is what the
world is like today.
You can start a business
spending just about nothing.
What were we looking for when
we were debating whether or not
to invest in Plunify?
We were looking for
what the world today now
calls unicorns,
privately held companies
worth more than one
billion US dollars.
These are incredibly
sexy creatures.
How sexy, you ask?
Well, a couple of years
ago, the dating app Tinder,
which I, as a boring married
man with four children,
have heard about
but never used, they
released a report that
said, what can you do
or what occupation can you have
to increase the odds that you
get a right swipe on Tinder.
Here are the results.
Look at men first.
Number one is pilot.
Tom Cruise, Top Gun,
always been true.
An incredibly sexy profession.
Look at what's number two--
founder/entrepreneur.
Back when I was in
the dating pool,
if you were to announce that you
were a founder or entrepreneur.
That's a good way of telling
people that you have no job.
But today, this is an
incredibly desirable profession
for both men and for women.
So we're out hunting
for unicorns.
We're considering this
investment in Plunify.
A couple weeks later, I see a
very different kind of beast.
I'm now in Durgapur in
the eastern part of India,
visiting something created
by a massive company.
This is something
created by Medtronic.
If you don't know
Medtronic, it is
the world's largest standalone
medical device company.
Now, India should have
been its leading market.
India sadly has
more heart disease
than any country in the world.
One of Medtronics
flagship products
is the pacemaker, a device that
gets implanted in your chest
to regulate the flow of
electricity to your heart.
But Medtronic sales in
India were minuscule.
You spend five minutes in
India and you understand.
Most people pay for health
care out of their own pocket.
A $1,000 device is simply
unaffordable to many people
in India.
Even worse, primary care
doesn't work that well in India.
You might not know that
you need a pacemaker
even if you could afford it.
Well, Medtronic,
truth in advertising,
working with a consulting
team at Innosight,
came up with an innovative
way to crack this problem,
not by inventing new
technology, but by developing
a new business model called
Healthy Heart For All.
Three key components
to the business model.
First, direct-to-consumer
marketing,
like the truck
that you see here.
Second, rural diagnostic
catch, where in an afternoon,
you could test 300
or 400 people to see
if they needed a pacemaker.
Third and most
critically, the world's
first loan program for an
implantable medical device.
Think about that for a second.
If you go to a bank and take
out a loan for something
like a car, if you don't pay
the bank back, what happens?
What does the bank do?
They take the car back.
They repossess the asset.
If you get a loan
for a device that
gets implanted in your chest,
and you don't pay the loan
back, what does the bank do?
Recollection of repossession
is a little bit more
challenging in
those circumstances.
But eight years later,
drafting on principles
proven in micro-finance,
community lending,
and so on, tens of
thousands of people
have been through this program.
Hundreds of
bottom-of-the-pyramid consumers
have received loans.
And there had been
virtually zero defaults.
I came back from
Durgapur and thought
about these two experiences.
When you first hear
the example of Plunify,
if you're inside
a large company,
you say, what hope do we have?
If you can start a business for
nothing, how can we compete?
Here's the challenge.
If you were sitting
in a meeting listening
to that pitch from Plunify,
what would stop you
from copying that
idea in the market?
Nothing.
Yes, it's never been
easier to start a business.
But that also means
it's never been easier
to copy a business, which means
it remains brutally difficult
to scale one.
Yes, we get the
unicorns that emerge
out, the Go-Jeks and the
Ubers and the Grabs and so on.
But for every one
that succeeds, there's
hundreds if not
thousands that fail.
Contrast that to Medtronic.
I could tell you every single
detail of what Medtronic did,
every single detail, and
what could you do about?
Nothing.
You don't have a
patent on a pacemaker.
You don't have access to
all the doctors in India.
You don't have the
understanding of the market
that Medtronic does.
There are literally
three companies
in the world that could
do what Medtronic did.
As I reflected on
this, I realized
I had framed the
problem incorrectly.
That, in fact,
what Medtronic did
and what other large
companies have done
is they have followed this
pattern of combining together
assets of scale with
entrepreneurial energy.
That is the path to
changing the world,
that, in fact, large
companies that think and act
in the right way can be
massive agents of change.
They can go and confront
what our co-founder, Clayton
Christensen, famously called
the innovator's dilemma,
and they can turn
it, like Medtronic
did, into the
innovator's opportunity.
Act two, the challenge.
It's easier said than done.
I was giving a
speech in Singapore
a couple months ago
with a number of leaders
from big retailers
and big consumer
packaged goods companies,
and I asked them,
give me a word to
describe what makes
it hard to drive innovation and
growth in your organization.
And you can see this beautiful
word cloud that was created.
I want to focus on this
word right here, inertia.
In my mind, this is
the biggest challenge
for large organizations
that are seeking
to have impact at scale.
And let me illustrate
the challenge
by telling you a story
about one of my children.
This is my third child.
You'll see others of
my children as I go
through the presentation today.
This is my lovable
six-year-old goofball, Harry.
So let me tell you a
little bit about Harry.
Harry has a father, me,
who was born in America.
His mother, my wife
Joanne, was born in the UK.
Harry was fully
manufactured in Singapore.
He was born here in 2011.
You ask Harry where
he is from, he
is most likely to
respond to Mars.
That's the kind of kid he is.
He's a very creative,
very energetic kid.
In fact, if you ask him
to draw a superhero,
he illustrates himself
as Captain Creative.
Fun, loving kid.
His nickname at
school is Happy Harry.
Everybody loves him.
So imagine our surprise about
18 months ago in Singapore,
we received a letter from
our condo association
describing an incident
involving Harry.
Here is a copy of the letter.
"As shared, your children were
found vandalizing the flooring
at the multi-play court using
some materials on 16 October
2016."
This being Singapore,
of course, the action
was captured in the CCTV
footage as appended below.
What do you think were
the materials that Harry--
and if you look very
closely at the picture,
you'll see there are
four fuzzy images there.
Harry has two older
siblings and his father.
What do you think were
the materials that we were
using on the multi-play court?
AUDIENCE: Chalk.
SCOTT ANTHONY: Chalk is correct.
It was a Sunday afternoon.
The kids were bored
out of their minds.
They said, can we go downstairs
and draw a baseball pitcher
diamond on the multi-play
court in the basketball court.
I said, sure, why not?
No harm, no foul.
It's chalk from Smiggle.
It's going to go
away pretty quickly.
Let's go and do it.
You see on down here,
"It is most fortunate
that our cleaners
have managed to remove
the stains on the floor."
What do you think actually
removed the stains
on the floor?
AUDIENCE: Rain.
SCOTT ANTHONY: Does it
ever rain in Singapore?
Every once in a while.
An hour after we drew
the baseball pitch,
the skies opened up.
All the chalk was washed away.
Yet still here, we received
this threatening letter
describing the horrid
behavior of our children.
This is what happens to us.
We enter the world
in a natural state.
We are curious and
creative when we are born.
And then we go to school, and
we learn there's a right answer,
and there's a wrong answer.
We go to work in organizations.
We learn there's a
right way to do things,
and there's a wrong
way to do things.
Harry came after this and said,
should I not do that anymore?
Should I not go play?
Should I not experiment?
Should I not draw?
To which we said,
of course you should
continue to do these things.
But when you get
inside organizations,
you have real challenges.
You're an executive like this.
You know the statistics.
Google has published
some of these things,
describing the benefits
that come from innovation.
You know your shareholder
returns will go up.
You know psychological
safety will increase
the performance of teams.
You know these are things
that you want to do.
You dream about being the
innovation super-hero that
can make all of
these things happen.
But then you deal with
the power of inertia.
You deal with the existing
processes, your metrics,
your incentives, your norms,
your decision criteria,
and your strategy, all of which
pull you back to yesterday
and make it hard for you
to go and create tomorrow.
You're not going to be
an innovation superhero.
The best that you
can do is attempt
to break out Innovation Man.
Who is Innovation Man?
Watch the video.
INNOVATION MAN: I
am Innovation Man.
I am here to get you all
fired up about innovation.
Are you fired up?
SPEAKER 1: I'm fired up.
INNOVATION MAN:
Are you fired up?
SPEAKER 1: I'm fired up.
INNOVATION MAN: I
said are you fired up?
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
INNOVATION MAN: Why
are you fired up?
SPEAKER 1: I don't
have any idea.
[INNOVATION MAN SCREAMS]
SCOTT ANTHONY: This is an IBM
commercial from 10 years ago
that is on YouTube if you want
to go and see the commercial.
This is based on a true story.
About 12 years ago now, we were
working for a large health care
company in the United States.
They said, what does it take
for us to innovate at scale?
We said it's complicated.
There's a bunch of
stuff you got to do.
You've got to go and
attack all of these things.
You need a new
strategic direction.
You've got to change
your metrics and so on.
They said that
sounds complicated.
Isn't there an easier answer?
So they' removed us as
consultant of record
and hired a
creativity consultant.
They gave them a
seemingly simple answer.
The answer they
provided was spandex.
They suggested that everyone
on the top leadership team
dress up as their favorite
innovation superhero to show
the organization it was a new
day when it came to innovation.
Predictably, this had
absolutely no impact.
Today, the only thing this
company is happy about
is 2006 when this happened
was before ubiquitous camera
phones, so there's no
photographic evidence
that this actually happened.
There is no innovation
superhero that's
going to ride to the rescue.
If you are truly to
unleash all the power
inside your organization,
you need a different answer.
Act three, the answer.
I can't give you a problem
without giving you a solution.
Let me introduce our latest
book, "Dual Transformation,"
which describes our view
for how you confront
the dilemmas of disruption.
The answer is basically
in the title of the book.
Transformation means a
change in form or substance.
We're not talking about
doing what you are currently
doing a little better, a little
faster, or a little cheaper.
We're talking about
a fundamental change.
a liquid becoming
a gas, the organizational
equivalent of the caterpillar
becoming the butterfly.
How do you do that?
Well, the answer here is
in the dual in the title.
We don't suggest that you
follow a monolithic change
effort where you do one thing.
Instead we suggest
that you follow
two parallel
transformation efforts.
The first is what we call
transformation A, where
you reposition today's business
to make it more resilient.
I think the clearest global
example of this today
is Netflix.
I was down in New Zealand
a couple of months ago
giving a talk.
I asked people, how many of
you subscribe to Netflix?
75% of hands go up.
Of course, a decade ago, that
would have been unimaginable.
Netflix's business at the
time was delivering DVDs
through the mail.
Today, of course, most people
who are enjoying Netflix
are watching streaming
videos over the internet.
Netflix, of course, has
done other things as well,
moving from packaging other
people's content to selling
its own content,
allowing it today
to be one of the biggest
media companies in the world.
Now it hasn't
redefined its industry.
It's still a media and
entertainment company.
The end customer is still hiring
Netflix to do the same job
that it did before.
But the way in
which it has done it
has fundamentally transformed.
That's transformation A.
Now, I'm taking since you
are at Google that you're
a pretty smart audience.
Let me ask you the
killer question.
If the first part of
dual transformation
is transformation A, what do
you think the second part is?
Transformation B. We only got
one person to respond to that.
But still, that is
the correct answer.
Transformation B is where
you go and create tomorrow,
where you go and take
the capabilities that
make you special and
selectively leverage those
to go and build a
new growth engine.
Of course, this is what
Google-- as you pull up
to the alphabet level, this
is what you are trying to do.
You're trying to
say that we've got
a core business or a
set of core businesses
that we're going to run as
efficiently, as effectively
as possible.
And we're going to go
and place some bets
to bring us into new spaces.
This is the new
growth engine that
has the potential to create
the next wave of growth
for your organization.
There's one more part to the
dual transformation equation.
Transformation A is
repositioning today.
Transformation B is
creating tomorrow.
Note these two circles overlap.
The idea that we offer
in dual transformation
is not unrelated
diversification.
It's not saying you pick up
cash flow from one business
and you use it to invest in
a completely disconnected
business.
Instead we're talking
about wading straight
into the territory that
Christensen famously called
the innovator's dilemma
and finding a way to very
consciously, very carefully link
A and B together, where you go
and pick up those unique,
precious special assets
and break free of
that dilemma and use
them to do something that few
other companies in the world
could do.
If the only thing you're
bringing to the equation
is cash flow, it's
a very hard game
to win in today's fiercely
competitive world.
There's the basic idea
of transformation.
These are some of
the examples that we
have in the book and
some of the materials
we've done around the book.
I'm going to give you
one of these examples,
then I'll ask you to
pick another one for me
to share with you.
So the one I'm going
to share is the one
that we have in the first
chapter of the book.
It is Janssen Anyone
know who Janssen is?
AUDIENCE: Pharmaceutical.
SCOTT ANTHONY: Pharmaceutical
arm of Johnson & Johnson.
That's exactly right.
So Janssen is a critical
part of Johnson & Johnson.
It's about 30 billion of J&J,
70 billion global dollars--
global revenue in dollars.
So about 10 years ago,
the arm was in decline.
The unit was in decline.
Sales had declined for
two years in a row.
A number of its important
drugs were coming off patent.
A new leader, Joaquin Duato,
launched a dual transformation
effort.
Transformation A was
change in the way
that Janssen developed
and discovered drugs.
Historically, what Janssen did
is got the best scientists it
could find, put them
in a laboratory,
and prayed that they would
discover some kind of molecule
that would ultimately lead
to a pharmaceutical drug.
They relied on randomness,
hope, and hiring the best people
they could find.
They did two things differently.
The first thing they
did was to focus.
Rather than have people
work on anything,
they picked a select
few number of diseases
where they would
understand those diseases
at a very deep
level, so they could
focus their scientific effort.
The second thing they did was
to embrace open innovation.
There's no way Janssen
thought that we could possibly
have all of the best
scientists in the world.
So let's get good, let's
get great at working
with scientists
wherever they might
be, in research labs, in
universities, at startups,
and so.
At the beginning
of the story, It
had the lowest R&D
productivity in the industry.
Today, it has the highest.
It hasn't redefined
its industry.
It hasn't gone into new
markets as it has done this.
But it has fundamentally
changed the way
that it discovers drugs.
That's been its
transformation A.
Janssen today makes
30 billion US dollars
selling drugs that allow you
to treat and manage disease.
What do you think would
be disruptive to that?
What do you think is
Janssen's transformation B?
$30 billion treating
and managing
diseases,
pharmaceutical products.
What disrupts that business?
Prevention, so if you
never get diseases.
They started a program a
few years ago under the name
Disease Interception.
The idea was as we understand
the pathogenesis of disease,
as we're beginning to have
smart, connected devices that
are giving us in-depth
understanding of humans,
as we decode the
genome, we can create
the equivalent of a check
engine light for an individual.
So it can say, Scott,
you think that you're
a healthy 43-year-old male,
but the light is blinking.
We see diabetes in your future.
And we've got an answer for you.
Not a pill, but a program
that you can follow that
can allow you to intercept this
disease before you ever get it.
A hugely disruptive
idea for Janssen,
but one that has tremendous
growth potential,
and one that has
the potential to do
a lot of good in the world.
So that's still
transformation at Janssen.
I've got eight other
things on my Brady Bunch.
That's probably a reference
that's lost on most people
in the audience,
but there you go.
In my Brady Bunch board
up here, what else
do you want to hear about?
AUDIENCE: Singtel.
SCOTT ANTHONY: Singtel.
So Singtel and
telecommunications in general
is a pretty simple story.
So transformation A, broadly
speaking, is voice to data.
So what you're using your phone
for is fundamentally different.
That business model and
the operational model
is fundamentally changed.
Transformation B
for Singtel has been
moving into new spaces,
cybersecurity, big data,
analytics, mobile marketing,
over-the-top video, and so on.
These businesses today are
about $1 and 1/2 billion
of revenue for Singtel.
Still a small part of its
portfolio, but rapidly growing.
And in each case, Singtel is
bringing something special
to the party.
They're not just saying,
let's go into markets
where we've got no right to
play other than our cash flow.
Mobile marketing is an example.
They have lots of in-depth
information about who you are
and what you're doing that
allows them, through purchases
[INAUDIBLE] and other things, to
do some very interesting things
in that space.
I can do that one so
quickly, I'll take one more.
What else do you
want to hear about?
AUDIENCE: Manila Water.
SCOTT ANTHONY: Manila Water.
So Manila Water is an
interesting example.
This is a regulated utility
company in Manila, of course,
in the Philippines.
Transformation A
for Manila Water
has been moving from providing
regulated utility water
services in the
Metro Manila area
to providing essentially
water utility as a service
to other parts in
the Philippines
and then Indonesia and
Vietnam, the theory being it's
gotten so good operating
in markets like that,
that it can essentially
create a business model that
allows it to expand
beyond Manila
and to other territories.
Transformation B is moving
from regulated water
to other related services.
An example of this is
in Metro Manila today,
there's about a $30
million business
where people will go and get
pure water from the Manila
water source.
They'll go and run it
through an ionizer, which
does nothing to the water.
They'll put it in a
big bottle, and they'll
sell it at about 1,000% markup.
And the target
consumer for this is
someone who lives in a
home that has rusty pipes.
So the water that comes out
of their tap isn't very good.
Manila Water said we can do this
business better than anybody
else.
It's a very different business,
unregulated, et cetera,
but it allows Manila Water
to take its capabilities
and move it in new directions.
All right.
One more.
AUDIENCE: Adobe.
SCOTT ANTHONY: Say that again?
SCOTT ANTHONY: Adobe.
So Adobe, I think, is
one of the clearest
and simplest examples
of dual transformation.
10 years ago, again, a business
that was essentially flatlining
had brought this software
to seemingly every person
who might want to use it.
Its share price was
stagnant, its sales
were stagnant, et cetera.
Transformation A, moving
from packaged software
to software as a service.
Still the same software
packages, but delivered,
of course, all over the cloud.
Very different business model.
Transformation B,
moving from its software
solutions to marketing
services and analytics,
the purchase of Omniture, the
big move in this direction.
Today, marketing services
and analytics is about 45%
of Adobe's combined revenue.
A stock that had been stagnant
has grown at 20% compound
annual growth for a decade,
which is pretty impressive
for a 30-plus-year-old company.
So we managed to make it through
almost half of the board here.
Again, there's other
descriptions of this on the web
or in other places.
But that's the basic idea
of dual transformation.
Act four, the
leadership implications.
The second half of the book
describes four key behaviors
that leaders need to follow
to successfully manage
transformation.
Let me go through
them pretty quickly.
The first is the
courage to choose.
One of the basic parables in
the change management literature
is if you want to drive
change in an organization,
you need a quote, unquote,
"burning platform."
This is a very bad metaphor,
because if you are literally
standing on a burning
platform, think about what
your strategic choices are.
Either you do
something incredibly
risky by jumping into the
ocean and hoping that someone
will rescue you,
or you stand still
and get burned to a crisp.
That's not an attractive
set of options.
The best leaders
have the courage
to choose before the
platform is on fire.
A great example of this is
Mark Bertolini at Aetna.
Mark Bertolini becomes
the CEO of that
now leading health insurance
company in the United States
near the end of 2010.
There's no burning platform.
The business is healthy.
Record revenues, record profits.
The Affordable Care Act,
otherwise known as Obamacare,
had just been passed
in the United States.
There are 45 million
customers that Aetna
has to figure out how to serve.
It would be incredibly
easy for Bertolini
to spend the next five years
executing yesterday's model
and ride off into the sunset.
He didn't do that.
Instead he made the decision
to blow the business up.
His theory was health
insurance as we
know it in the United States
is going to die at some point,
and I'd rather do it when
my business is healthy
and I'm not forced to do it,
because then I've got degrees
of freedom to act differently.
If you follow that
industry, you know
that that company, Aetna, with
CVS Caremark earlier this year
to create a very distinct,
maybe even disruptive,
player in the health
care industry.
Behind Bertolini's thinking is
the old John F. Kennedy line,
the best time to fix your roof
is when the sun is shining.
How do you know?
How do you get the signals that
suggest it's time to change?
This is something that many
executives struggle with,
because they say,
these are things
that are going to
happen in the future.
How do I know what tomorrow's
going to look like today?
You can spot tomorrow today if
you look in the right places.
Remember the great quote
from William Gibson
that the future has
already arrived.
It's just not very
evenly distributed.
What can show you
tomorrow today?
What are places that you need to
look if you want to understand
what the future will look like?
Where do you go to
go and spot what
tomorrow's going to look like?
This is, by the
way, meant not be
a rhetorical question, but a
question where I hear examples
from you.
What are good signs to show you
what the future will look like?
AUDIENCE: What kids are doing.
SCOTT ANTHONY: What
kids are doing.
So I mentioned before
that I've got kids
and I was going to show
you pictures of them.
Here's the second child picture.
There is my 10-year-old
daughter Holly.
Holly is an invaluable
source of guidance to me.
I sit locally on the
board of Mediacorp.
If you don't know Mediacorp,
it is the leading media company
in Singapore.
Its dominant business
model is broadcasting
videos, television channels,
linear television, and so on.
I watch the way
Holly consumes media.
And of course, you know this
exceedingly well at Google,
and you know that this
model is dying very quickly.
And Mediacorp needs to
change quickly to adapt,
because Holly will
never sit down and watch
linear television.
Never.
Sometimes I will see her on
the couch watching Netflix,
but I'm much more likely
to see a scene like this.
Here's Holly getting
ready to go and watch
her favorite performer
on YouTube, DanTDM.
Does anyone know who DanTDM is?
AUDIENCE: No.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
SCOTT ANTHONY: No--
usually, you are not
of a demographic that
would watch DanTDM,
but there are a couple
in the room that might
have kids who watch DanTDM.
Well, I'll tell
you who DanTDM is.
He is a YouTube star.
He's got about 20 million
followers on YouTube.
He narrates himself
playing video games,
most predominantly
himself playing Minecraft.
Now, I played video games
when I was growing up.
I had every video
game system known
to man, the TRS-80, the
Atari 2600, the ColecoVision,
the Nintendo, Super Nintendo,
Sega Genesis, Sega Dreamcast,
et cetera.
Lots of video game systems,
maybe not so many friends.
Different conversation,
different day.
So I get playing them.
Watching people narrate them
to me is a little bizarre,
but Holly and her friends
will watch for hours
when people are doing this.
And again, 20 million followers,
reliable press account,
say, sponsorship fees of about
20 million British pounds
last year.
This is what media is
going to look like.
Kids are great
signals of the future.
Startups are great
Hackers and artists are
great signals as well.
The picture here is me onstage
in a conference in Australia
last year with a cyborg.
The cyborg is Neil Harbisson.
He's in the red jacket on the
left side of the screen for me,
right side to you.
He has an implant
in his brain that
allows him to perceive
different parts of the spectrum.
There is an IP
address in the implant
that allows you to
email pictures to him
that he can perceive.
I was talking to one of his
friends, a fellow cyborg
at the conference.
This friend had implants in
his ear that went to a plate
in the back of his head.
I said, it looks like it's
pretty hard to sleep at night.
He said, yeah, I
don't sleep all that.
Well, I said, so
what's the benefit?
He said, well, with
this, I can sense changes
in atmospheric pressure.
I was not yet sold,
so I asked them
what benefit does that give you.
He says, well, I know
when it's raining outside.
I said, well, I do too.
I just look out the window, and
I sleep pretty well at night.
And this seems
kind of weird when
you see it in its early days.
But, of course, things
that are fringe today
are mainstream tomorrow.
So you want to, as a
leader, do things like this.
Go and spend time at the edge
of the periphery of an industry,
because that will show
you tomorrow today.
Second thing you
need to demonstrate
is the clarity to focus.
This is not planting hundreds
or thousands of flowers in hopes
that some will bloom.
This is going in launching,
yes, a few select,
strategic moonshots.
This is decided the
things that you will do,
and most critically, the things
that you won't do as well.
Many organizations
tell us, we wish
that we could do more things
when it relates to innovation,
but we don't have the resources.
We find almost every
organization has the resources.
Many have succumbed to the
plague of the zombie project,
the walking undead.
The project that, if
you are honest about it,
will not materially move the
growth needle in any major way,
yet it still shuffles on,
sucking all the energy out
of the organization.
You need the clarity to focus
on both what you will do
and what you won't do.
How do you go and actually
make the decision about what
you should and shouldn't do?
Well, this is where you
face one of the biggest
challenges of an innovator.
I've been in the field, as I
mentioned in the beginning,
for close to 20 years.
In that time, I've seen hundreds
if not thousands of ideas
to innovate.
Every idea in its
early days is the same,
because it's partially
right and partially wrong.
The challenge you
face when you're
standing at the first
mile of innovation
is you don't know
which part is which.
Now, the way many large
companies go and address
this challenge is they try to
get to truth through analysis.
They go and interview experts,
and they go and commission
market research.
And they come up with
elaborate financial forecasts
in the hopes of coming
up with a perfect plan.
There is no such thing.
You follow this
approach, you learn
a life lesson taught by the
great American philosopher,
actor, and occasional boxer
Mike Tyson, who once said,
everybody has a plan until
they get punched in the face.
What you need to
demonstrate as a leader
is the curiosity to
explore, recognizing
that your ideas are wrong.
And the only way that
you will get to truth
is through smart,
conscious trial-and-error
experimentation.
While doing this, you need
to de-fang one of the biggest
enemies of innovation, something
that's illustrated in a book
called How Google Works-- so
something that I hope resonates
with at least some of you--
the hippo problem,
where decisions
are made not by data
and not by experiments,
but by the highest
paid person's opinion.
This is a bad
example here, where
option is replete with data.
Option B has no data, yet
the hippo rules for option
B. It's sometimes even worse
when it comes to innovation,
because both sides of
the board are blank.
And the hippo has great
intuition about yesterday,
but not great intuition
about tomorrow.
So what do you do to
confront this challenge,
to deal with the reality
that every idea is partially
right and partially wrong?
I suggest drawing inspiration
from the Wright brothers.
You go back 120
years ago, the world
was perplexed with the problem.
They had wondered for years,
for generations, for centuries,
why it was that birds could
fly but humans couldn't.
The problem was particularly
acute at this time,
because the machine age,
the Industrial Revolution
was upon us, yet we still
haven't cracked the problem.
Most would-be aviators built
versions of their planes,
took them to high
places, and tried to fly.
Those planes crashed.
They couldn't go and try again.
The Wright brothers framed
the problem fundamentally
differently.
Before they flew a plane,
they built kites and gliders.
The great thing about kites and
gliders is when they crash--
and they always do--
nobody gets hurt.
Even more critically, in
1902, the Wright brothers
hacked together bicycle spoke
wire, cardboard box, and a fan
to create this, a wind tunnel.
Imagine how it
felt. At that time
everybody else was working
on crazy contraptions that
were crashing, and the Wright
brothers here were able to,
in two exhilarating months, to
run more than 200 experiments,
testing 30 different
wing designs,
getting real data that
ultimately led to breakthroughs
like wing warping that
allowed the Wright
brothers to create the
world's first flying machine.
This is what you need to do
at scale in organizations,
have the ability
to design, execute,
and learn from experiments.
This is easier said than done,
because the problem is kites
still crash.
Wind tunnels still don't work.
There's a lot of failure
on the way to success.
Now, if you talk to
anybody about failure,
they'll say something
similar to what I'll
show on the video clip here.
This is from an interview I did
with the then-CEO of Procter
& Gamble, A.G. Lafley,
a decade ago, 2008.
When I asked him his view on
failure, this is what he said.
A.G. LAFLEY: You learn far
more from your failures
than you do from your successes,
far more from your failures.
I can remember every
time I struck out
in high school baseball.
I can remember every time
I failed, OK, at P&G.
And I failed a lot.
Now, what we're trying to
do now is fail a lot faster,
fail a lot cheaper,
so we fail more
and get on to the next idea
or the next innovation that
may become a commercial
success, but failure's
incredibly important,
and learning from failure
is very important.
SCOTT ANTHONY:
Again, leaders today
are conditioned to
say things like this.
We love failure.
We encourage failure.
They cite Google.
They cite other examples
in Silicon Valley
about how failure is
almost a badge of honor.
But then you get
the reality, where
you get something like this.
This is Tom Fishburne,
the same cartoonist
who did the hippo problem.
If you don't follow Tom,
you absolutely should.
He does great illustrations
that bring business challenges
to life.
What breakthrough idea did
you want to share with me?
This is what happened to
everyone who failed beforehand.
This is a huge challenge
in organizations.
What do you do to combat it?
You make sure that
people recognize
it's OK to dare to try.
This is a consciously
stolen name.
This is a high
prestige prize that's
given out by Tata Sons, the
largest conglomerate in India,
every couple years.
There are two and
only two things
that you need to do to
be eligible for the Dare
to Try prize.
What do you think they are?
Two things.
You have to have failed.
And this is not a heroic
overcoming an obstacle
and still succeeding.
I remember I was talking to
one organization in Singapore,
and I said do you
encourage failure?
They said, we absolutely do.
I said give me one example
of when you've done this.
They said, well this team
was really struggling.
It was not hitting
any of its deadlines.
It was running over budget.
And then they
worked really hard,
three months, nights,
weekends, and they delivered.
I said, there is
no failure in this.
This is heroically
overcoming obstacles.
Let me give you an
example of failure.
About 10 years ago,
we had an idea.
We would create CD-ROMs.
This would not be me singing.
Thankfully, again,
we avoid that.
But the idea was to take Clay
Christensen, we'd take me,
we'd take other people
in our organization,
we would create CDs that
had training material,
and people would buy these CDs.
And this would be a new growth
business for our company.
If anyone would like
a large amount of CDs,
we still have them
in our inventory.
There's no happy
ending to this story.
It didn't work.
We've got Christmas
presents to give out
for years to come still.
That's the first criteria.
It has to have failed.
What's the second?
The idea must have
failed, but/and
you have to have learned
something from it.
Because any time
you dare to try,
there are three good
things that can happen.
You can learn we should
never do that again.
And if you learn that in
a resource-effective way,
that's a good, not bad outcome.
You can learn that
we should only
do this if you've generated a
strategic option that gives you
space to work in the future.
Or most powerfully,
in many organizations,
this is their
entire origin story.
You learn that
instead of doing that,
we should do something
completely different.
These are all valuable
learnings that you
want to capture and codify
when you go and do new things.
Final leadership
characteristic-- I'll do this,
then I'll give you my short
version of the fifth act,
then I'll open it
up for questions--
is that conviction to persevere.
My co-author, Clark
Gilbert, second name
you see listed up there, speaks
from firsthand experience
when he says, what
I've described
here is the toughest challenge
a leader will ever face.
He's done this in two very
different organizations,
a media organization
and a university.
And it is indeed
incredibly hard.
In the eighth chapter of
"Dual Transformation,"
we lay out some of the
predictable crises that will
happen as you try to do this.
You won't get this done in
a month or in a quarter.
It's going to be a
multi-year journey.
And in that journey,
you're going
to have crises of
commitment, you're
going to have
crises of conflict,
the new business
and the old pieces
will fight for resources, you
will have conflict of identity.
It happens every single time.
You need to have as a
leader the conviction
to persevere through these
conflicts or the first time
you hit one of these crises, all
of your efforts will crumble.
Let's go back to Johnson
& Johnson for a second.
The picture you see here is the
cover of "Dual Transformation"
in front of the credo.
The credo is etched into granite
in the headquarters of Johnson
& Johnson in New
Brunswick, New Jersey.
You could imagine
people in J&J would say,
disease interception,
that is crazy.
We make $30 billion a
year selling products that
allow people to treat diseases.
Why would we want to
eradicate diseases?
This isn't in our
shareholders' best interests.
Well, at J&J, these are
very short discussions,
because you point to the credo.
The credo starts by saying
our first responsibility is
to the doctors, the nurses,
the patients, the mothers
and fathers, and everybody
else who uses our products
and services.
It goes on to say
that we then have
to think about our employees.
We then have to think about the
communities in which we live.
And our final responsibility
is to our shareholders,
who, if we do all
of these things,
have the right to
get a fair return.
The shareholder isn't first.
The shareholder is last.
The conviction to
persevere must be
grounded in some kind of
purpose for why you're doing it.
You can find purpose in
just about everything.
There's a great example,
from about 20 years
ago in Singapore about
an organization that had
a seemingly strange problem.
It had too many
repeat customers.
And because it had so
many repeat customers,
its employees were very unhappy.
What type of organization
do you think this is?
Where do you not want
repeat customers?
Say that again?
AUDIENCE: Prison.
SCOTT ANTHONY:
Prison is correct.
I sometimes will have
people say health care.
Every once in a while, we'll
have people say funeral homes.
This is not the
zombie apocalypse.
It is indeed prisons.
So there were high
rates of recidivism,
and because of that, the
guards were very unhappy.
So a new leader comes
in and does many things.
But one of the things
he does is create
a new statement of purpose.
We are captains in the lives
of people who are temporarily
in our custody.
Our goal is to get them
out as quickly as possible
and have them stay out
for as long as possible.
Today, some of the lowest rates
of recidivism in the world,
some of the highest rates of
job satisfaction in the world.
This is what's required if you
are to drive fundamental change
in organizations.
Fifth act.
Fifth and final act,
the call to action.
This is the greatest
present that I ever
receive from a project
team, a consultant
team that was working for me.
This is a bobblehead doll
affectionately known as Scoda.
This is my head grafted on the
body at the Star Wars character
Yoda.
The team told me they were going
to try and hit a deliverable.
And I told them this is not
a try or try not situation.
This is it do or
do not situation.
If you are to do
any of the things
that we've talked about here,
you have to go and do it.
By way of metaphor, let me
introduce my third child
into the discussion.
My oldest child,
my boy, Charlie,
a few years ago said he wanted
to learn to ride a bike.
What came next?
We did not discuss the
theory of bike riding.
We did not watch any YouTube
videos about bike riding.
We created no PowerPoint slides.
We did no spreadsheets
modeling bike riding.
Instead, we put Charlie
on a bike, and he tried.
He pedaled and he fell down.
He got back up.
He eventually learned
how to ride a bike.
Today, he is a proficient rider.
He can get from point A to point
B without too much difficulty.
He practices enough, he
can be a skilled rider.
He takes performance
enhancing drugs,
the Tour de France
might be in his future.
Don't do drugs.
They're very bad things.
You've got to do the
same thing to bring
to life many of the
things we talked about
during today's conversation.
It starts with the
declaration of innovation.
Remember what I said
earlier, we enter
the world in a natural state.
Human beings are, by
their very nature,
curious, creative people
that desire to grow.
This is innate inside all of us.
There are seven
specific simple things
that you can do to begin
to make some of the things
I've talked about here
day-to-day habits.
It starts by tripling
the amount of time
you spend with customers.
However much time
you're spending today,
it is not enough.
There's no get-out-of-jail-free
card for this.
You can't say, well, I'm in
an internal support role.
I don't have any customers.
Everybody has people
they're trying to serve.
It might be a colleague.
It might be a coworker.
What your job is is to
identify or understand them
better than they
understand themselves,
so you can spot new
paths to innovation.
Second, triple
the amount of time
that you spend at the periphery.
Remember, the future
has already arrived.
It's just not very
evenly distributed.
The more time you
spend at the edges
with children, with hackers,
with startups, the more
you will be able to
see tomorrow today.
Third, make a regular habit of
asking three simple questions
that will highlight new
opportunities for innovation--
why, why not, and what it.
Fourth, prepare yourself to take
those punches from Mike Tyson.
Run an experiment today.
It doesn't have
to be complicated.
It can be a new route into work
or a change in your morning
routine.
If you're struggling with
an innovation problem,
this is a great way
to condition yourself
to go and try new experiments
and do new things.
Don't let a lack of
money be an excuse.
Find ways to experiment
without spending anything.
Think about the wind tunnel.
Think about those
people who started
the business at Plunify.
There is a ton you can
do today without spending
any money at all.
The final two tips remind
you to go to the place
where innovation
magic always happens.
This is one of the most
persistent findings you see
in the innovation literature.
Magic happens at intersections,
where different mindsets
and skills collide together.
A simple way to get
to the intersections
is to read a magazine in a field
you've never thought of before
or go to a trade
show in an industry
that you don't
care at all about.
If you've got an innovation
puzzle in your brain,
you're going to see a
unique way to address it
if you go and do this.
Finally, call up the weirdest,
most iconoclastic person
you know.
Ask them to introduce you to the
weirdest person that they know.
If it's you, you've got
a short phone catch up.
But otherwise, you have
diversified your network
for innovation.
You've got new sources to lean
into when the next disruptive
problem arises.
I end all of this on
a note of optimism
I showed you pictures
of three of my kids
as we went through
the discussion.
Here they are live and on stage.
Not quite live and on
stage, but there you go.
This is not the BBC video.
No one's going to run behind me.
We've got Charlie,
my 12-year-old.
We've got Holly, now 10.
We've got Harry, who's six.
Here's the newest addition.
There's Teddy.
He's two.
I don't have any
stories about him
other than thinking
he's awfully cute,
so I put them up
on a picture here.
But what these four
children have taught
me is this lesson that
I've repeated here,
that we enter the world as
curious, creative people.
And I now have a firm belief
that the world's biggest
untapped source of
energy isn't in the wind.
It isn't in the water.
It isn't in the sun.
It's inside our
large organizations
that are filled with human
beings that were once like this
that are now shackled
and constrained,
not realizing their
full potential
related to curiosity
and creativity.
This is my life's mission.
I view my job as a
parent to make sure
that my children never lose
their love of learning.
I view my job as an advisor
to large organizations
to help leaders of these
organizations release,
harness, and amplify the latent
energy that exists within.
After all, as
Archimedes once said,
you give me a lever long
enough and a platform on which
to place it, and I
can move the world.
The platform that you
have at your organization,
the platform that people have
at many large organizations,
is unbelievable.
It's the sort of thing
that the startups are all
fighting like crazy to create.
The potential is there.
I hope the ideas that
I've shared today,
the ideas that are documented
in some of the other writings
that I and my
colleagues have done,
I hope they make your leverage
just a little bit stronger.
The rest, of course,
is up to you.
Thank you very
much, and good luck.
[APPLAUSE]
While the mic is going
to you, I will tell you
about my favorite
Harvard Business Review
article from the last year.
I don't know if you've seen it.
I'm reflecting the fact
that we're both Scotts.
There was an article in
the Harvard Business Review
that says you essentially
become what your name is.
So they ran this research
study that showed
people randomized pictures.
And they were able to, at a
statistically meaningful level,
guess somebody's name.
So they'd show four pictures.
They'd say that's a
Scott, and that's a Jay,
and that's a whatever.
So I know someone who's a Scott.
I can tell the years that
they were born between,
because the name went like
this, and I know roughly what
they're going to look like.
So anyway, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
was just curious
to find out the epilogue
to Harry's vandalism story
and what kind of
lessons he learned
and you learned from that and
maybe the condo management
association as well.
SCOTT ANTHONY:
Yeah, so you know,
it's an interesting story.
So I don't fault the
condo, the people
who sent the
letter, because they
were doing what they thought
they were supposed to do.
And you get the theory, right?
It's the broken windows theory.
So if we stop the small
stuff, the big stuff
will never happen.
And what we talked
about with Harry is,
yes, there are certain
circumstances or certain things
that you would do that
would be problematic.
So if you spray painted rather
the chalk, if what you wrote
were religiously
offensive or whatever--
there are certain sets of
things that you shouldn't do.
But free play by
children with material
that washes away easily
is not the sort of thing
we're trying to constrain.
And I've now used this story to
talk to people in the Singapore
government, because
in my view, this
is Singapore's biggest problem.
Singapore is a remarkable place.
You see that which
has been created out
of basically nothing.
But all the constraints
that exist in the system
take the human population
and human capabilities
and really, in today's
quickly changing world,
I think constrain them.
So I think Singapore's
challenge/opportunity
is to go and arrest--
not arrest, put in jail--
but to go and fight against
some of the historical legacy
systems that lead to
this being the norm.
And Harry is as creative and
curious and crazy as ever.
He now doesn't think
he's from Mars.
Neptune is his new home.
That's what he
said this morning.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thanks for the talk.
My name's Ignatius.
I'm not [INAUDIBLE].
But my question
was if we're meant
to triple the time we
spend with customers
and on the periphery, what would
be your advice as to what we
should spend less time doing?
SCOTT ANTHONY: Not coming
to talks like this.
But the-- I was talking
to Jay about this before.
This gets back to
the idea of inertia
being one of the biggest
enemies that you face,
any organization faces.
I bet you that a large portion
of the meetings that you go to,
a large portion of
the things that you're
spending your time on, if you
were to step back and say,
is this something that is
material, has value added,
and so on, I bet you
the answer would be no.
I bet you that you've
got zombie things that
are on your calendar.
And the example I was
sharing was our organization,
we've got a call every Thursday.
We call it a
leadership team call.
Our organization
is about 100 people
inside a larger organization.
But within the 100 people, about
30 of those 100 join the call.
So it's a pretty big part of
the organization that does it.
And if you ask people why do
we have this call Thursday
at 8:00 AM Eastern
Time, most people
would say because it's
always been on the calendar.
And I was there when
we created the call,
and I know why we
created it, but it
was created to solve a
problem that no longer exists.
But we still just dutifully,
religiously go to this meeting
even if it wastes a
lot of people's time.
So I would ask, what is the
equivalent of your Thursday
call that you could get rid of
to go and create the space for?
And I'm sure it's there.
Or you should just work harder.
Either one.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is George.
So my question is--
because over the years,
I think a lot of companies,
the traditional enterprise,
are talking about
the transformation
or the dual transformation.
The concept has been
around for many years.
And some companies have been
successful the journey, right?
Some companies are
being not so successful.
So based on your
observation, so what
are some of the top trait for
those so-called successful
transformational companies?
And what are some of the thing
that you think companies are
not doing so well
in their journeys,
like potentially people
can learn from them.
SCOTT ANTHONY: So I
would say read the book.
The book is an effort to
answer that as much as we can.
But I think if you look at
the most common challenges
that people run into, one is
they define it too narrowly.
So they're not looking
at the A and B.
They're doing an A or a B.
And doing just one of
those is insufficient.
If all you're doing is A, you're
missing tomorrow's great growth
businesses.
If all you're doing is B, you're
leaving your core business
in a place where someone's
going to come and attack,
and that's a problem.
So often, we see people
who do it too narrowly.
That's one challenge.
The second challenge we see
is this capabilities length
that I went through
very quickly.
This is really hard.
It's very tricky.
It's very subtle.
We've got a full chapter
in the book devoted to it.
We talk a lot about
Clark and his experiences
at his media organization
and his university.
Getting that right,
thinking about how
you very selectively
pick the capabilities
you want to leverage.
You make sure you don't
take some things that
will corrupt your new
business even though they're
great for your current business.
That's a really
hard thing to do.
So that's a common
failure mechanism.
And the third is they don't
recognize it's a journey.
Rather than viewing
it as a journey,
they say, OK, this is our
90-day plan to go and transform.
It doesn't happen.
We have the metaphor in the
book of a three-year journey.
It might not be three.
It might be 18 months.
But it might be five
years in some cases.
And the impatience in
organizations I think
is a big challenge.
There's lots of other
things you could
talk about, about
strategy and so on,
but those would be at least
three places that I would
start, and three
things that we try
to offer different
answers to in the book.
AUDIENCE: You know, at
Google, for instance,
we tend to come in and offer
these sort of point solutions.
And I'm sorry if this
question is a bit leading,
but what is it that
a company like Google
should be doing whenever
we're talking to our customers
rather than just offering them
point solutions whenever they
are trying to make a change,
a fundamental change,
in their business and
how they approach things?
SCOTT ANTHONY: So if you
look at that idea of tripling
the amount of time you spend
with customers, if you know
Innosight, you know Clayton
Christensen and his writings,
you know one of the
big ideas we focus on
is the customer's
job to be done.
What is the problem
they're trying to solve?
And in a B2B world,
it's pretty simple.
Well, along said dimension.
The business of
business is business.
So what you always want to
do when you're in a service
provider space, when
you're in a B2B space
is understand the context in
which your customers operate
and think not just about how
you deliver a cloud install
or whatever, but what's
the business context
in which they're operating.
What are the challenges
they're facing?
What are the other
things that need
to happen for them to
increase their ability
to be competitive,
to engage employees,
et cetera, et cetera?
So this mindset of
always asking yourself
what actually is
the customer's job
to be done and not
just the one who I'm
having the conversation
with, not just the buyer,
but what's the buyer-- what is
the circumstance in which they
sit, and who are the other
influencers, et cetera,
et cetera.
That's, I think, the mindset
that you always need to have.
And I think it's not
dissimilar to what
we need to think about to be
good advisors to companies.
So we might get hired
by an executive who
says, I need to think about
this new growth business
or whatever.
But what they
actually need to do
is have a story that they
can tell to a shareholder,
or they might have a
board of directors member
that's causing them
a lot of trouble,
or they might have
a power struggle
that they're trying to--
whatever.
We need to understand
that, because giving
the right technical answer
to the question asked
is typically insufficient
to ultimately
have impact in your
line of business,
in our line of business as well.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask
two more questions
that were submitted
as part of a survey
that we provided earlier.
One of them was, can I
start a business with $0?
SCOTT ANTHONY: Yeah,
so the Plunify example
is a perfect example of that.
And if you looked
at the screen, it
was the excited space of
cloud-accelerated chip design.
I do not remember at all
what that is, but whatever.
It was a business that
we started from nothing.
And this is the norm today.
A lot of businesses are
started for nothing.
And of course, there
are lots of businesses
that you could do as
an individual that
require no capital investment.
Starting a business for nothing
is actually quite trivial
to do.
Scaling it, on the other hand,
that still requires capital.
And this, again, is one
of the great advantages
a company like Google has.
You have more capital
than probably any company
in the Western world.
So that gives you
advantages over startups
that are scarce of capital and
have to fight fiercely and have
to fight against
would-be competitors,
et cetera, et cetera.
You have the ability to
think and act at a scale
that few other
organizations can follow.
So yes, you can start
a business for nothing.
But remember, so can
everybody else in the room.
So if you've got
an idea, and you
start to get some
early traction,
then everybody else is
going to go and try and do
the same thing.
Whereas here, at Google, you've
got unique, hard-earned assets
that you've built over your
20-plus-year history that are
really difficult to replicate.
And think about what you can
do with that as an advantage.
It's that example or
the idea of having both.
So you both have
the assets of scale
and the entrepreneurial energy.
When you bring the two
of those things together,
it is a really
powerful combination.
AUDIENCE: OK, and I
guess that takes me
into one of the other
questions that was asked.
For those of us then that
have made that choice
to join a larger organization
and try to change the world,
what can we do as individuals
to innovate inside
of our own roles and companies?
SCOTT ANTHONY: So the seven
things that I had on-- this
is from-- the list of seven
things is a slightly modified
version of something that I had
at the end of "The Little Black
Book of Innovation" called
The Innovator's Pledge.
Doing those things
repeatedly, spending more time
with customers, spending
more time at the periphery,
running experiments,
and so on, you
don't have to be a
CEO or somebody who's
got a big budget, who
runs a business, to do it.
These are day-to-day
habits that you
can bring into your own
individual behavior,
to your team's
individual behavior.
And the thing that I'd
ask you to think about
if this is a struggle for your
team, group, or department,
is why.
What are the things,
the blockers,
that are standing in
the way of success?
Sometimes it's a norm
that needs to be changed.
Sometimes it's a system
Sometimes it's you
as a leader, what
you need to do differently
in order to role model
a different behavior.
But it all starts with
going and recognizing
that to do something different
that creates value, which
is how we define innovation,
there are a set of practices,
there are a set of habits that
increase the odds of success.
So we've just got
to do those things,
and we've got to
do them repeatedly.
And we have to enable other
people in our team, group,
or department do
those things as well.
AUDIENCE: Let's have round of
applause for Scott Anthony.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT ANTHONY: Thank you.